welcome back we are up to episode 8 and
how to program in C++ in this episode he
numbs an enum is some kind of
enumeration so let's update this thing
as usual enums and enums are generally
used as some kind of switch or state
control or something along those lines
because what they are is they are a
variable and we'll go ahead and make one
up here at the top we'll do that up here
above our while loop that way it doesn't
instantiate a bunch of different times
and how you do these is start with the
word enum which is a keyword then you
give your enum structure a name like
we'll just call it choice I tend to do
these in all caps some people don't but
it doesn't matter this names a new type
of variable that you can instantiate and
then you do the squiggly brackets and
you give the different values your enum
could be so in our and our choice here
we only want a 1 through 4 but usually
when people make enums they make an
invalid case too so we'll do that make
an invalid case and we'll make a well
we'll call it add subtract multiply
divide and this can make it a little
more clear when you're going through
your logic because you can see exactly
what your case is called given what
you've named it these don't have to be
caps I just like to do them in all caps
and they follow those standard names of
the variable or you can start them with
an underscore if you want you can use
lower case numbers of them etc etc then
you put one of these semicolons at the
end and now you have this in your scope
so you can use it say we want to so if
we want to use it will instantiate one
of them ok let's make a new choice enum
and we'll just call it in lower case
choice
or maybe I'll put it underscore in front
of it to make sure it doesn't overlap
with any other variable cult choice but
that's up to you so now we've got this
we can use and now how this works is
this first one is a zero the second one
is a one and it actually looks like it
tells you if you hover over them and so
on however you can start it at different
numbers if you want like maybe we want
this one to be 12 now it's 12 and the
next one increments as you go on it
automatically does that we'll go ahead
and we'll just we'll just leave it the
default of starting at zero so you can
assign these based on their integer
value you can say okay well let's make
our choice equal to one and that'll make
it equal to add or you can also say
choice equals add sometimes you have to
scope it and say we're talking about
this enums value of add so you'll see
this too but at starting off remember we
just want it to be invalid and then we
jump into our loop and instead of using
this integer of choice we're going to
use this so we'll go ahead and put this
down here and I will also point out
another way of instantiating these if
you're declaring it at the same place
you may have seen this before
you can do it that way and then
instantiates it right after declaring it
but if you're getting it from another
header or something you're gonna have to
do the variable name and then what a
variable type in the name this works too
just wanted to show you that so as we go
into our loop we set at first we set our
choice to invalid and then we're gonna
switch on choice and of course these
have all been renamed yeah because 1 is
equal to ad so if they put 1 it'll set
at ad they put 2 it'll set it to
subtract and so on so then it switches
on that choice and now we have a case
where it says 1 and while this will
probably work since
they are those values a standard thing
to do is while you're switching on this
enum so it's only gonna look for these
values in the switch statement and some
IDs an ID a being visual studio code
here will autumn will autocomplete your
cases if you put in enum and switch and
help you fill it out a little quicker
but what we can do now is make it just
even more clear and put our actually
known values in here and it's just uh
yeah this makes a little more clear so
you'll see gnomes alive when there's
state control in a program and let's go
ahead and compile and run this and make
sure our I didn't program in any
handy-dandy errors oops
and it appears I did it doesn't like
this seein of
the choice so what we would probably
have to do here is figure out a little
fancy way to get around it so we still
have to find a slightly different way of
doing this so what is a better way to do
this
turns out this is probably a bad example
of a gnomes because see anything the
value of it join console one of the
value is not really to conducive to
setting these you usually want to set
these by some other state in your
program some other case so it would just
end up being a lot of code if I if I did
that because I would basically need some
other kind of statement to set that up
so if we go back to our old version of
it and then we say after the fact well I
guess we could do one sort of fancy
thing here and put a little while choice
is invalid
so this actually does bring up a way for
us to loop in our CN and make sure we
get a valid entry because at the end of
this we could say if choice is greater
than zero and choice is less than five
now this is a very weird way of writing
this but it does accomplish one goal of
making sure we're giving our program
valid input because it's only gonna
accept greater than zero which is gonna
be one and up and less than five which
is gonna be four down so it'll clamp it
between one and four and then we'll say
we'll set our choice and here we can set
it directly to that integer we might
have to do some sort of static cast
we'll see if it likes this or not so
it's not gonna change from invalid
unless we have a valid choice number but
we could say something like and just let
the user know maybe we'll put an escape
is to make a literal of that single
quote right there okay and let's see how
this does now it doesn't seem to like
the conversion from integer to choice
and I believe what we have to do here
here's a static cast
and now it's happy because it's gonna
convert whatever this is to this new
enum type because this is not while it's
set to some type of integer it's not
actually an integer so we have to cast
it using static cast you know lookup
more about static cast online if you're
confused about it but it's very similar
to the old casting style I showed you
before where you could do something like
if we want to change these two of float
used to and the before C++ used to cast
with just parentheses in front of your
variable name so that would cast this
double to a float but the newer way of
doing that is with static cast and then
the type you want to cast it to here and
then type your casting there so guess
we'll be covering a tiny bit of that
here too so it would be more like this
to do it the new C++ way and I think
that is just to help handle some more
error cases okay so now this should work
let's go ahead and compile one last time
and we'll run it and let's plus three
four multiply seems to be going to the
right place look at our calculation
let's do another let's try an invalid
entry of nine and it tell us invalid
tells us invalid entry of nine try again
so now we've sort of abstracted our
choice out into a two an enum and the
switch I this might be a bit of a
confusing episode but it's really
important to understand how these enums
work and I think I've covered the
majority of it also you can start them
negative if you want but if we change
that to negative one this first one will
be zero and that throws off our entire
logic right there so it's rather
important based on the way we've created
this for this
to start at zero you can use enums
anywhere you want your code to help make
your switch cases cleaner and anywhere
else you might have some state based
logic they can really come in handy I
hope you enjoyed this episode and I'll
see you in the next one to keep on code